It's been harder for Trump to
find people to perform at his
inauguration than it is to find
people to perform in his
administration.
A number of acts have refused,
or outright canceled, uh, and
those who are performing are
gearing up for what will
probably be their last ever
appearance onstage.
See ya in hell Three Doors Down.
Now, this is actually a picture
of the '70s band Thee Dog Night,
but we don't know what Three
Doors Down looks like, so...
We just... that's what we had.
But the performers that do sign
up for their moment in the
freezing January sun will
probably be treated like royalty
for a few minutes.
So comedians, I want you to give
me some items or demands that
you might find on a Trump
inaugural performers backstage
rider agreement.
Uh, Dave Anthony.
>> The ability to feel shame.
>> HARDWICK: All right, points.
Posehn.
>> Crisp white sheets.
>> HARDWICK: All right, points.
Stephanie.
>> Some Mexican food with a wall
built around it.
>> HARDWICK: All right, points.
Posehn.
>> A fourth door down.
>> HARDWICK: All right, points.
Anthony.
>> A bowl of grabable pussies.
>> HARDWICK: All right, points.
Grabable... Stephanie.
>> A gift basket of ammo and
Keystone Light.
>> HARDWICK: All right, points.
Oh, a winning combination.
Brian Posehn.
>> A scientist, so you can burn
him with cigarettes.
>> HARDWICK: Points.
Stephanie.
>> A copy of the Constitution
and someone who can read.
>> HARDWICK: Ah, points.
Very good.
And Mr. Brian Posehn.
>> A dumb red hat with a stupid
fucking thing on it.